at Fox News Alert we are less than 48
hours from the end of title 42 and
Border towns are bracing for a
potentially historic surge of Migrant
Crossings which is already ramping up
and is seen here in this exclusive video
from Fox news's bill milugen out Kinkos
Tommy Lauren joins us Tommy what's your
reaction when you see that video from
Bill malusian other video from Griff
Jenkins all of our amazing reporters
down there at the border and you also
hear border officials say hey if you
thought it was bad before just wait
until you see what happens in 72 to 96
hours what's your reaction to that
yeah this is just the pre-game this is
just the beginning of what's on and pop
and come Thursday and I also want to say
as you mentioned thank goodness for our
Fox news reporters that are down there
covering this while most of the media
has turned a blind eye to this border
situation that's been going on for two
and a half years now six million plus
illegal immigrants in this country thus
far there's already hundreds of
thousands of massing ready to come in
after title 42 expires and to put that
in perspective for the audience my home
state of South Dakota is under 900 000
people so that's over six South Dakotas
that have come in in the last two and a
half years and about one South Dakota
waiting to come into this country so if
you don't think this is going to impact
you and your community and your state
because you're not on the border think
again this is going to impact every
single American we already have a
shortage of resources we already have an
economy that is struggling now add in
millions of people who are a lot of
these people are low-skilled labor and
imagine the problems that we're going to
have in the next year the next five
years the next 10 years and I would say
a mandate to our next Republican
president I know nobody likes to say it
but there better be millions of
deportations on the table when we get a
Republican president because this is
unsustainable yeah I mean Tommy mayorkas
keeps saying that they've been divided
administration's been preparing for this
for 18 months I know I keep getting hung
up on this but what have they done to
prepare is it the app is it sending last
minute 1500 troops active duty troops to
the border which by the way is just
helping with transportation and trying
to take the the bulk of stress off the
border patrol agents but even with that
U.S border Patrol Chief they just
revealed that over a three-day period
there's been more than 26 000
apprehensions including three sex
offenders and a wanted felon seven
thousand gotaways and those big seizures
of drugs like meth and Fentanyl this is
with title 42 in place it's going to be
a disaster whenever it's out
you're exactly right and what you
mentioned about what the bite
Administration is trying to do to appear
like they've got the situation under
control these 1500 troops God bless them
for going down there but they're not
there to enforce the Border they're
there to expedite the process everything
this Administration has done thus far
has been to move people into this
country faster to process people faster
I actually spoke to a border patrol
agent who saw me in Nashville last week
and he came up to me with tears in his
eyes saying Tommy I work in the El
Centro sector in California we are not
prepared for what's going to happen next
week we are not prepared to process
these number of people it's not going to
be Catch and Release it's not even going
to be released it's just going to be
walk on through because we do not have
the means to do anything to enforce our
border or to even process these people
in a way that ensures our national
security you mentioned the number of
people that have got in let's talk about
the godaways let's talk about the people
that got in with bad intentions because
our border patrol agents were too busy
processing and babysitting that's the
real concern here the world know those
our enemies know the border is open and
they will definitely exploit it they
would be stupid not to it's a golden
opportunity for them Tommy what other
reason could this Administration have
for the way that they've handled this
over the past two and a half years then
that this is exactly what they want to
happen
yeah this is not a crisis this is an
opportunity you don't sit back and allow
millions of people to come into the
country we know that that doesn't have
to happen because we saw the Trump
Administration take steps to enforce our
border and we had apprehensions at
record lows so they knew this was coming
they allowed it to happen because they
wanted it to happen I quite frankly
believe that they want to give these
people voting rights amnesty they want
to add them to the Democrat voting block
so this is all a Shameless attempt at
doing just that and unfortunately it's
working not only drugs and you know
people here illegally do we have to
worry about but what about what diseases
they have we have no idea where these
people have come from Tommy lahren thank
you so much for your time this morning
we appreciate it I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis